هذا الصباح هاجم الرئيس
عضوًا آخر في الكونغرس على تويتر
هذه المرة إنه رئيس لجنة الرقابة في مجلس النواب
إيليا كامينغز
، كتب أن منطقة كامينغز هذه عبارة عن
فوضى مقززة تنتشر فيها الفئران والقوارض
إذا أمضى المزيد من الوقت في بالتيمور ، فربما
يمكنه المساعدة في تنظيف هذا
خطير للغاية و  مكان قذر لا
يريد أي إنسان أن يعيش
فيه موبوء ، وعادة ما يكون مخصصًا
للإشارة إلى القوارض والحشرات ،
لكننا رأينا الرئيس يستدعي
الغزو لانتقاد المشرعين
قبل أن ترى نمطًا هنا قبل أسبوعين فقط ،
هاجم الرئيس ترامب لعضوة في
الكونجرس من الأقليات لماذا لا تفعل ذلك.  إنهم
يعودون إلى الأماكن المكسورة تمامًا والمليئة
بالجرائم التي
جاؤوا منها تذكيرًا بأن ثلاثة منهم ولدوا
هنا جميعهم موبوءون بالأمريكيين
كما يقول قبل أسبوع من تنصيبه في
يناير 2017 ، عضو الكونجرس جون لويس
قضى المزيد من الوقت في الإصلاح و  يساعد
منطقته التي هي في حالة مروعة
ومتداعية ناهيك
عن دونالد المليء بالجريمة  قام ترامب بتغريد
أكثر من 43000 مرة أنه أهان
الآلاف من الناس لأنواع مختلفة
من الناس ، لكن عندما غرد على تويتر حول
الغزو ، كان الأمر يتعلق بالناس ذوي البشرة السمراء والسود في
سبتمبر 2014 في ذروة
حالة طوارئ صحية عاجلة ، لماذا
نرسل الآلاف من
الجنود المدربين السيئين إلى هناك.  بولا من المناطق الموبوءة بالإيبولا
في إفريقيا يجلب الطاعون إلى
الولايات المتحدة ، أوباما غبي جدًا لدرجة أنه يقول إن
هناك ثورة تدور في
كاليفورنيا ، حيث توجد العديد من مناطق الملاذ الآمن ، واحدة
من هذا المفهوم السخيف المليء بالجرائم
والتكاثر الذي ينتشر في الولايات المتحدة ، كما
يقول الرئيس يقول عن عضو الكونغرس
منطقة كامينغز
التي لن يرغب أي إنسان في العيش فيها ،
تعرف من فعل السيد.  لقد تم إحضار الرئيس الذي قمت به
منذ اليوم بالخارج
من المستشفى إلى اليوم الذي غادرت فيه
للكلية وما زال الكثير من الأشخاص الذين أهتم
بهم يقومون بتحدي لا شك فيه
ولكن الناس فخورون بمجتمعهم
ولا أريد أن أبدو
ما يفعله الناس ويذهبون إلى العمل هناك ،
فهم يهتمون بعائلاتهم هناك ، فهم
يحبون أطفالهم الذين يتعهدون
بالولاء للعلم تمامًا مثل الأشخاص
الذين يعيشون في مناطق أعضاء الكونجرس الذين
يدعمونك يا سيدي ، إنهم أمريكيون أيضًا